[Musique]
plusieurs milliers de candidats qui
avaient reçu une réponse favorable de
parcours sup le soir se sont réveillés
le matin avec un avis négatif
madame la ministre vous expliquer ce
dysfonctionnement qui toucherait 7% des
candidats par un problème d'informatique
pourtant dans un premier temps vos
services ont incité est autorisé par
écrit les établissements à pratiquer un
taux de sur réservation jusqu'à 50% dans
un second temps vous les avez autorisé à
dépasser ce taux alors pourquoi cette
panique et surtout pourquoi reporter sur
les établissements la responsabilité
d'un revirement qui la conséquence de
vos décisions politiques que vous
n'assumez pas je n'ai jamais parlé d'un
problème informatique
j'ai simplement indiqué que 2% des
formations s'étaient trompés lorsqu'elle
avait deux façons de manuel saisi le
nombre de candidats sur la liste
d'appels c'est une erreur humaine c'est
une erreur factuelle
c'est une erreur qui évidemment est
extrêmement regrettable et c'est
pourquoi j'ai aussi demandé à
l'inspection générale de regarder les
raisons précises qui explique ces
erreurs de façon à ce qu'elles ne
puissent pas se reproduire
l'autre sujet auquel vous faites
référence est un sujet qui est
totalement différent
rappelez vous l'été dernier un certain
nombre d'entre vous sur ces bancs comme
à l'assemblée nationale
indiquez la crainte qu avait un certain
nombre d'établissements et notamment les
classes préparatoires de ne pas remplir
leur formation à cause de la mise en
place de parcours sup c'est pourquoi en
accord avec ces établissements nous leur
avons proposé de pouvoir avoir ce taux
d'appels légèrement supérieur nous
continuerons de défendre un enseignement
supérieur accessible à tous les
bacheliers sans discrimination le bug de
parcours sup n'est pas informatique
madame la ministre le bug de parcours
subtil et social
[Musique]
qui c'est ici dans cet hémicycle ce que
veut vincent lambert qui pourrait
affirmer savoir ce qu'est les médecins
eux mêmes ne savent pas jusqu'où pouvons
nous considérer qu'une vie ne vaut plus
la peine d'être vécue ne faut-il pas ma
derniers ministres tirer dès à présent
sur les leçons de ce drame je vous
remercie
hier soir la cour d'appel de paris a
accepté la requête des parents de
vincent humbert et a ordonné la reprise
des traitements afin de faire exécuter
les recommandations du comité des droits
des personnes handicapées de l'onu
l'équipe médicale en charge de vincent
lambert appliquera ces mesures
provisoires
je n'en dirai pas davantage sur ce cas
particulier
aujourd'hui encore plus que jamais nous
devons respecter l'intimité la douleur
de la famille et des proches de vincent
lambert
la seule leçon que nous pouvons retenir
de cette situation est que chacun
remplisse ses directives d'anticiper
[Musique]
vous assurez monsieur le député que le
président le gouvernement a parfaitement
travaillé avec la députée plus
globalement je crois monsieur le député
que la question vous causez et vous
l'avez su le sénateur je prie la haute
assemblée de et d'accepter mes excuses à
monsieur le sénateur merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs
[Musique]